state attorneys general and yes that is
the correct plural and if you already
knew that I'm sorry that high school was
such a rough time for you believe me I
know being a teenage grammar nerd is
something from which it is difficult to
recover and look I do realize that they
show about state AG's sounds like a
tedious prospect just watch the start of
this 2006 panel discussion on c-span in
front of an electrified crowd our panel
today features three distinguished and
very very different and bipartisan
attorneys general I gotta say that was a
bit of a dick move by the c-span camera
man there he didn't have to pan across
those empty seats but he did it anyway
as if to say look even the panel's
friends didn't show up and I'll tell you
what that panel did wrong actually if
you want a live audience to listen to
you talk about state AG's simply don't
tell them in advance we filmed this show
in front of a live audience
you think we told them what this shows
about of course not they were explicitly
told that this was a taping of the
Rachael Ray Show and I promise she'll be
out any minute now but look it is worth
the effort to learn about state AG's
because they are very important and yet
most of us probably don't know who ours
is although if you live in Indiana I am
very excited to introduce you to yours
please meet Curtis Hill AG by day
although by night something very much
different I was toying around with it
and discovered that I sounded sorta like
Elvis we're caught in a trap I can't
walk out
because I love you too much baby
we saw the Attorney General do all the
hits I don't know if you've noticed but
I don't look much like Elvis to be
honest I'd noticed that frankly it's
difficult to notice anything besides the
most sadistic inseam in the history of
tailoring that looks like a marshmallow
bisected with fishing wire and that's
all it looks like most ladies are
actually elected meaning they belong to
political parties and they run campaign
ads like this striking one from Michigan
when you're choosing Michigan's next
Attorney General ask yourself this who
can you trust most not to show you their
penis in a professional setting is that
the candidate who doesn't have a penis
I'd say so well certainly and arguments
although to be honest if you asking me
which candidate I trust most not to show
me their penis I'd have to go with
Dennis he he can't show me his
penis why that mean old raccoon still
has it that woman is running for
attorney general in Michigan it's one of
30 states where voters will be selecting
their next AG on November 6th and those
elections are going to be unusually
competitive some estimate that more than
a hundred million dollars will be spent
on AG races this year that's up to three
times more than ever before so tonight
let's look at who AG's are what they do
and why they matter and let's start with
what they do because typically they
serve as a state's chief legal officer
and the people's loyal with
responsibilities ranging from a criminal
law enforcement to consumer advocacy to
and everything in between
the landmark multi-billion dollar
tobacco industry settlement in the 90s
the one that killed Joe Camel that was
thanks to state AG's this year's
blockbuster report on abuses by the
Catholic Church in Pennsylvania that was
thanks to a state AG you know who put
out that raging wildfire in Northern
California that was firefighters use
your head
why would state AG's have been involved
in that use your instincts here
the fact is the fact is though AG's
often work on politically neutral
matters and they still do but in recent
decades they've also become
significantly more partisan one small
sign of this is that while all AG's
belong to the National Association of
attorneys general or nag around two
decades ago Republicans formed a
separate committee just for them raga
and the Democrats followed suit with
dagger and I do know that rocket and
dagger sound like twins from Dutch
folklore that teach children about right
and wrong
Rocka always milks the cow when its
udders are swollen but darker is off
making nonsense with a goose when darker
is given no dinner
this is justice but arguably the most
high-profile way in which this job has
become more partisan is the extent to
which a GS belonging to one party have
teamed up to bring lawsuits against the
federal government now that used to be
relatively rare but starting in the
Obama years the number of those sort of
lawsuits skyrocketed it was Republican
AG's who successfully limited the
Medicaid expansion of Obamacare and
suing the government became a point of
pride for AG's like Texas's Greg Abbott
what I do is I go into the office I sue
the federal government and then I go
home
I've sued the Obama administration now
25 times over the last four years yeah
but that is not the smirk of a guy who
just goes into the office sues the
government and goes home is it that's
the smoke of a guy who goes into the
office sues the government adjust the
office thermostat without telling anyone
steal someone's sandwich from the fridge
farts in the elevator and then goes home
now Apple has since gone on to become
governor of Texas but his successor Ken
Paxton was no less eager to sue the
Obama administration just listened to
his wife proudly describing Paxton's
love for lawsuits in what apparently I
legally have to call a song I'm a
pistol-packing mama yes I
I'm a pistol-packing mama
Esaias I'm a pistol-packing mama and my
husband sues Obama again I never thought
I would say this but I would honestly
rather listen to moose knuckle Elvis
Shirley Temple get up in his living room
in a too-tight onesie now
Paxton himself is actually a really good
example of how a state AG's political
views can significantly impact their
work
he told County Clerk's that they could
refuse to issue marriage licenses to
same-sex couples he was a lead plaintiff
in a lawsuit that shot down an Obama era
rule that would have made four million
people eligible for overtime pay and
when the Obama administration tried to
extend protections for transgender kids
in public schools
Paxton sued and said this any man that
decides that they wanted to clear
themselves to be female for the day can
walk into your daughter's locker room or
bathroom it now opens the door for
anybody no matter what they are and how
they're thinking they can change their
gender for a day and have the ability to
walk into a women's locker room it's
just not right what the are you
talking about obvious bigotry aside
transgender people don't just switch
identity for convenience they are human
beings not read frogs that's right read
frogs
should the need arise can spontaneously
change from female to male I just hit
you with an unexpected frog fact in the
middle of talking about state attorneys
general I know what you're thinking
where the is Rachael Ray
in the next village I'm gonna write just
be patient be patient
she'll be here she's making frittatas
and you're all going to have a taste
now should be here just be patient
now now now Paxton has actually spent
almost his entire time in office under
indictment and is awaiting trial for
securities fraud but that is not evenly
ken Paxton related allegation I would
like to show you instead I'd like to
focus on one mentioned in a real attack
ad from his current opponent this is the
collin county courthouse where a dallas
attorney accidentally left a $1,000 pen
at the metal detectors this is Ken
Paxton the indicted Texas Attorney
General rummaging through the metal
detector trays and stealing that $1,000
pen and this is Ken Paxton the indicted
Texas Attorney General walking away with
a stolen pen vote Justin Nelson for
Texas Attorney General he will fight on
behalf of all Texans and he won't steal
no pain yes that's a relief although
thanks to that ad earlier I would also
like to know that he won't steal my pen
or show me his penis or for that matter
shown me his pen or steal my penis I
wouldn't need to know all his positions
on the penis pen show-steal continuum
still the larger point is state AG's are
increasingly partisan and when you look
at how ken Paxton has used his power it
is hard not to think that that is a bad
thing but partisanship can cut both ways
and now that Trump is in office
democratic state AG's are the ones
filing lawsuits against the president
and while you may have been unhappy to
hear people cheer for that
pistol-packing mama as husband suing
Obama I suspect it may feel a little
different hearing the Democratic AG of
Washington state say this we have 19
since the donald trump became president
we've filed 19 lawsuits against
administration so what do you say to
people who just think you have an axe to
grind against this guy why I plead
guilty
[Laughter]
you see it's interesting how your
feelings on soon the government can
change a lot based on who is saying it
it's like how I'm getting off here is a
fine thing for someone to say if they're
standing next to the door of a train but
a very rude thing to say if they are
masturbating on that same train
so look state AG's have a lot of power
and while many of us may not have been
aware of that corporations and other
special interests certainly have because
both rocker and dagger have been
increasingly aggressive about raising
funds and one way they do that is by
organizing events where they essentially
sell access to AG's ragga
especially has some pretty lavish
getaways where industries can mingle
with the AG's who are supposed to be
policing them as CPS found when its part
on one in South Carolina we saw at least
nine state AG's rubbing shoulders with
representatives from Koch Industries Big
Tobacco payday lenders and the NRA the
dress code resort casual CBS News
reviewed 88 donations over $50,000 and
found more than half of the donors had
matters under consideration by a state
attorney general or had recently settled
now rocker says there is absolutely no
quid pro quo there so I guess those
groups simply donated substantial
amounts of money because they wanted to
chillax to the max at a resort casual
clambake with North Dakota Attorney
General Wayne Stenehjem oh yeah he's not
just the AG of North Dakota he's the
mayor of margarita blue Wayne
parties hard he's an animal and
look some state AG's have been
ridiculously cozy with corporations take
scott pruett former head of the EPA he
previously served as Oklahoma's AG where
he had a very close relationship with
energy companies he sued the EPA 14
times and wrote the agency multiple
letters about policies that threatened
to impact local oil companies like Devon
Energy but when a reporter obtained
copies of Pruitt's correspondence with
Devon he noticed a weird coincidence the
letters that scott pruett had written
were identical copies in most cases of
draft letters that Devon had sent him he
had taken those letters and simply put
him on a stationery and sentiment as if
they were essentially the state law
enforcement official opinion it was like
holy exactly like he said holy
and that sure looks like Pruitt let an
oil company do his work for him although
to be fair maybe he just happened to
think up the exact same words in the
exact same order that they did maybe you
find that plausible personally I find it
about as plausible as I do the idea that
the family in a quiet place stayed
silent for 472 days Wow no one thought
Eid for more than a year that could
really be the title of the movie because
that is genuinely incredible so so state
AG's are powerful increasingly partisan
and over half of them are on the ballot
this year and Republicans are very much
ready for this fight as Arkansas state
AG and chair of raga Leslie Rutledge
will tell you when it comes to the
Democratic AG's I can't speak to what
they do I know they raise a heck of a
lot less money than the Republican AG's
do because we have been crushing it ok
so first again a bit of a dick move by
the c-span Caravan they're undercutting
her claims of crushing it with a cruel
cut away to her audience candy crushing
it but the fact is she is right Raja is
really out raising dark and it seems
they are now locked in an arms race for
funds which just cannot be the
healthiest way for this system to
operate naughty raga naughty dagger if
you keep keep behaving like that your
parents will tell you to de see which
like your sisters
now interestingly Rutledge is one of the
AG's up for election on November 6th as
is possible pen thief Ken Paxton and if
you live in any of these highlighted
States you have got an Ag race to vote
for and it is really worth taking a few
minutes to research the candidates
especially because many people who do
actually vote end up leaving the AG box
on the ballot empty so your vote for Ag
may technically be even more valuable in
Texas one poll showed that 39% of
registered voters didn't name who that
they would vote for for Ag because they
and I quote haven't thought enough about
it which sounds terrible but that's
actually a cause for genuine hope
because remember that is where Ken
Paxton is running and if there is one
thing sure to damage Ken Paxton's
reputation it's an awareness of Ken
Paxton's reputation so so please before
November 6th just think about your AG
race you can do it you've got nine days
left and I know that we've all been
asked to think about a lot this year
from Supreme Court nominations to gun
control to the energy of Pete Davidson's
penis it's it's been a lot and now I am
adding research your state AG race to
your list but it is honestly worth it
also if you do it you'll frankly be
amazed at the kind of tidbits that you
might find if you live in Wisconsin just
google Brad Schimel $10,000 coins and
you'll learn about how your AG managed
to spend ten grand of taxpayer money on
coins reading K AE D which stands for
his actual personal motto kicking ass
every day if you live in Arkansas Google
Leslie Rutledge karaoke 2016 so you can
see our friend from before absolutely
crushing it on stage
[Music]
wait did that guy just say sing it
Leslie I'm not sure that's encouragement
I think that might be an honest plea
sing it Leslie sing it
don't just drone it a rhythmically and
an inconsistent volume the bands in E
major and you're in H try and bring it
into the known musical universe Leslie
and look if you're in Michigan and even
if you are not please google Bill
Schuette e 1989 video here's their
current AG but he's not actually up for
election because he's running for
governor but it is still worth googling
that so you can watch him creepily
hitting on a woman behind the camera I
would be happy to move closer to the
land anything some things that may not
let you run the camera on admire your
tenacity appreciate your spirit of
Vincent van Gogh
Rembrandt Toulouse Lautrec oh that is
rough to watch I don't know how she got
through the interview without punching
him in the dick
but point here is a point here is taking
just two minutes to research your state
AG is a valuable use of your time and if
you are thinking that you don't have two
minutes you actually do because it's
11:28 right now I'm not saying goodbye
until 11:30 so go to vote for one one
org right now where you can find out if
there is an election in your state and
if so who your AG candidates are
seriously do it now you will not be
missing anything
I promise nothing entertaining is going
to happen for the rest of this show in
fact to help drive you away for the rest
of the broadcast a bagpiper will be
playing Leslie Rutledge's favorite song
she thinks my tractor's sexy take it
away
[Music]
yes
believe it or not these bagpipes make
this song even more unlistenable than it
already is
that is an ungodly noise no disrespect
turn this show off now and research your
AG and if you haven't already been
repelled into action I'll happily add an
accordion into the mix oh yes the sweet
sweet sound of a bagpipe are called into
x2 sounds that come together
what pop-tarts and fish gum two bunks
for what one.org
right now because I promise this just
isn't gonna get any better and don't
push me on this mentally sound
think again don't join me
should be watching this show anymore
[Music]
coming tonight
[Applause]
that we're never going to pay for
charters
[Applause]
how are you somehow the worst
ingredients in all this
any Jews because these guys are about to
get loud
[Music]